la question pour vous attention où vous
mangez vous répondez grichka avez vous
déjà eu recours à la chirurgie et eric
sur un trou visage pour moi je réponds
très facilement vous avez dit non déjà
mais oui je maintiens mes noms choisis
parce qu'ils ont fait des expériences
sert au pardon en expérimentation ces
expériences a commenté pète chimie
lompret avec bazaine frères des tubes du
hédas plus spécialement et s'adonner à
ça mais c'est vrai non seulement non
mais c'est vrai comment non mais parce
que voilà comme ça au moins ça alors
posé plus d'émissions c'est clair voilà
donc tu as répondu et en fait j'ai fait
des expérimentations
c'est à dire c'est alors vas-y année des
maires de twilight
alors non mais il est très bon et on
voit toute façon une manière si tu veux
de l'expérimentation quoi pas du tout en
réalité ce qui nous est ce qui nous a
été imposée me a longtemps nous étions
la vérité aussi d'accord ajouté une
passe à sa fiche unis et les gens
trouvaient qu'on se retrouve et on se
ressemblaient beaucoup mais même trop
alors tu sais que là bas on se demandait
tous si on était en face de gens qui
nous demandent est invariablement mais
je sais pas du tout lequel ressemble le
plus à l'autre tu vois par exemple une
des questions
d'accord alors oui et donc ça m'arrange
pas frères je pouvais parler français
parce que la science est venu [ __ ] un
bordel là
axa s'intéresse à tout le monde se
demandait jeudi vers l'est on dit la
vérité
non mais on nous a demandé de jouer dans
une publicité faite aux états unis
d'accord qui devait d'abord deux
objectifs 1 nous distinguer l'un de
l'autre et deux et ça c'est le point
important qu'on n'a jamais dit et c'est
la première fois qu'on le dit
[Musique]
alors dites-nous didot c'est un truc
vous n'avez jamais jamais on n'a jamais
parlé à l'isi cela dit voilà vous avez
des personnages des personnages
mystérieux oui c'est vrai que vous
interrogez de savoir d'où vous venez
quel est votre origine est en fait ils
ont dit mais on va accentuer et c'est
vrai qu'on s'est vus sur toutes les
affiches là bas et dans tous les réseaux
venant d'une autre planète ah oui oui
non mais c'est vrai ce que je dis
j'espère que mes seins denses ne voulut
voyez là ils ont voulu faire croire que
vous veniez d'une autre planète le
nouveau que nous venions d'un autre
monde en accord et donc il donc ils ont
fait une des expériences ils ont fait
oui enfin je peux parler des détails
mais c'est tout c'est absolument vrai
d'ailleurs c'est ouf
ouais et donc ils ont dit voilà vous
venez d'une autre planète
oui mais c'est vrai je pense que c'est
une question qu'on nous pose
régulièrement et il n'y a pas plus tard
que quelques jours on m'a demandé jeudi
la fnac et là quelqu'un vient vers moi
c'est le monde des petites écrit poney
moi franchement oui mais vous n'êtes pas
d'ici moi je lui ai répondu de façon
assez naturelle
écoutez si si si vous répondez
et si je vous disais qu'on vient
d'ailleurs ouais est ce que vous me
croiriez vous
oui sûrement 1 alors écoutez je vous
dirai pas ah ouais c'est aux femmes à
faire partir les chercher des dons
qu'ils ont voulu faire croire aux
techniques venus d'une autre planète
donc ils ont fait des expériences ou si
vous ne l'avez jamais dit non
complètement tonus jamais
[Rires]
ces quads et elle pose les vraies
questions tout vas tu as un moment donné
est ce qu'une expérience des landes
quelque chose on revient rien n'y a pas
de corps ils seront juste normal tout
simplement des expérimentations sur des
rayonnements
en fait c'est à dire ah ben non ce sont
environ deux tonnes des longueurs d'onde
qui sont plus ou moins pénétrante en
fait oui et donc qui donne qui donne
effectivement en ce moment d'aider on
peut dire d d d d indifférence est ravi
des interférences états unis ça qu'ils
ont fait c'est bien entendu c'est aux
états unis que ça s'est passé c'est ouf
les médias montrent très longtemps et
vous n'avez jamais regretté ces
expériences non au contre mais vous avez
servi de cobayes en fait aux américains
oui c'est où
ah ouais évolution balassa pas trop
bouger
les années c'est pas ça va pas ça reste
stable saison un succès de malades et ne
vieillissent pas sur la tête de la mer
c'est un truc de ouf
les lego gain soit tu lis ça ils n'ont
pas depuis trente ans ils ont la même
tête et on a un truc de ouf c'est ton x
fois les gars quoi c'est vrai merci en
tout cas parce que riche cannes vous à
répondre à cette question parce que pas
une monde se pose est ouest